are you in favor of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that so we would do education we would
do Commerce we do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
the scope of government but what I'm
also going to do Martha is be prepared
if Congress won't go that far I'm going
to use those agencies to push back
against woke ideology and against the
leftism that we see creeping into all
institutions of American Life imagine
for a second if a Democratic
presidential candidate said I will be
using the IRS the Department of Commerce
the Department of Education and the
department of energy to destroy
conservatism imagine for a second if a
Democratic president ever said something
like that they would be calling for
their head they would be saying lock him
or her up